a story today that you know they they
caught four high school kids that stole
the stuff from your locker room yeah let
me address that I love that did you guys
get everything back I I have no idea I
didn't have in check with all the kids
let me address that
um let's not
crucify and
punish these high school kids okay
whatever the
punishment that comes along with it all
right let that be that community service
or whatever is it but let's not abort
the rest of their opportunities and
lives because of a mistake because if we
were to really do a roll call of
mistakes at the age of 17 and 18 in here
I'm sure everybody would tip out of here
with the head down like we're in church
okay so let's make sure that those kids
atone for what transpired if it's
community service whatever it is but
they don't lose a opportunity to to
change their lives their kids they made
a stupid dumb idiotic mistake guess what
when I was seven and 18 so did I all
right so did you um I'm praying for
those kids it was very unfortunate that
that we were on the other end of that
and and some fans was stupid enough to
say well they shouldn't wear their jury
okay well you shouldn't drive your car
to work then somebody steal that so that
that's just how stupid that statement
was but let's pray for those kids man
lift them up and hopefully and
prayerfully they get another opportunity
what's probably going to happen is they
probably going to name them and you know
expose who they are and then all hell
breaks loose because we're a society
that likes to make a mockery of people
that are made sex in life when all of us
have so that's that's my take on
that